when you think back to producing one our
fantasy girl which forgive me that was
your first producing credit okay - now
you've six and then you have two more or
more in the pipeline right okay what how
was your vision of being a producer
changed so the first one you know you
had this one set of ideals and beliefs
and now all the way to to this these
upcoming projects so I think when I when
I got into Hollywood and as a producer I
had been working for three years to get
one project off the ground that fell
apart within a weekend oh wow that was
yeah that was and that happened in 2007
so Edgar and I had been working for
Edgar Bravo the writer director it was
my business partner at no restrictions
he and I had been working for years to
try to get these projects off the ground
that were like two or three of them and
we had gotten very far we were talking
about like you know getting into CAA
getting into the studio system getting
meetings with people that could make
things happen like very quickly if they
got behind you and so we had amassed a
good momentum and we had put a large
portion of the financing together so
when we did when our fantasy girl I was
not happy to be quite honest I wasn't
happy because we were starting from a
budget on another project of 2.5 million
and now we were going to tens of
thousands of dollars and you know it's a
huge drop-off there and and so
emotionally it's it's very difficult
because you want to be where you had the
potential you always knew that you had
the potential was validated by all these
other people that said you were good
took meetings with you based on the
script you know that kind of stuff that
those are meaningful things you go over
to 20th Century Fox you're meeting with
a head of you know the vice president of
production who read your script and
wants to take a meeting with you it's a
pretty big deal and you don't have any
agent or representation that's a big
deal that you feel good about that so to
lose all of that and start from scratch
it was I was upset I loved the script
when I read the first draft that he had
made it it stayed with me for hours and
I knew that that was always where I
wanted to go was to make films that you
know I removed moving to me I didn't
have to sit there and think about it
it's just like it's stirred in my head
so that was the motivation to get back
to where we were by doing that film so
what I wanted you know obviously when I
created that movie I wanted it to launch
our career I wanted it to change
everything that the doors were gonna
open because now all the relationships
that I have been building up for the
last three and a half years would see a
product of something that I was able to
do on a micro budget and you got
critical acclaim and it did really well
in sales I mean yet we were talking to
people at Netflix the head Ted I forgot
his last name but the CEO I mean this is
still when they were smaller and still
open but they can't I mean I wrote to
him in an email and he handed me off to
one of the yeah I mean it was it was
serious it wasn't like you know and I
know all these things I mean it's it's
frustrating for filmmakers gonna hear
that because everybody wants that but at
the same time my idea of producing was
to get into the Hollywood studio system
and become a big producer and have you
know lots of money but I didn't realize
that in essence what we were doing was
we were separating ourselves from that
part of the industry
not that I reject them or think that
they're wrong or anything like that I
mean they their business they can do
whatever they want but today coming
forward six films later and we have the
internet and we have alternative media
and you have other methods and ways in
which you can reach thousands of people
very quickly with little to no overhead
that's that's the sweet spot for me as
an independent film producer I mean you
have to imagine there are also companies
now that exists kind of like ours not as
production companies but companies out
of New York and elsewhere that have a
team of people and an overhead and a set
budget that actually go out and do the
same work that I'm actually doing as a
producer one on one with all of these
different people in the alternative
media because the the subject matter
speaks directly to that group of people
whereas in a larger system where you
have more overhead you have more risk
you have a lot of other things you have
to spend millions of dollars to ensure
that you're gonna get a delivery on pay
out for your investment and your
distributors and all your talent and
everything else that's in there so they
are hiring these companies now to go and
find these groups of people that exist
online in these communities and market
the film to them it's quite interesting
now it's not first tier distribution
level obviously it's not theatrical and
it's not television cable but these
secondary secondary areas like social
work groups and and other groups that
are dealing with causes and and and all
of that they they would have to cast as
wide of a net as possible and spend tens
of millions of dollars to possibly reach
those people where if you go directly to
them today and you have credibility and
you can you create a relationship with
the person who's interviewing you all of
a sudden you're opened up to their
entire audience and we're talking like
thousands of people some of these people
on YouTube have two three four hundred
thousand or more subscribers they also
have patreon which you know is another
and you get email blasts I mean we saw
when we went out and did with the
child's voice or latest film on human
trafficking we went directly to these
individuals and the moment that we did
the interview and it was published and
the moment that that patreon went out
we're talking like hundreds of sales
within days on Vimeo on Vimeo alone and
we haven't even gone to Amazon and done
prime and all of that so when you're
when you're looking at that and you're
seeing the potential plus the reaction
the reactions are instant with these you
know they're they're writing comments in
the YouTube comments they're writing
them on IMDB they're writing a lot of
you know organically organic growth
organic spread you go on doing keyword
search on Twitter you know and you look
at how all none of these people follow
you they don't even follow people that
you follow they heard about it and
shared it they were moved by it you
receive comments you receive emails you
hear first-hand testimonies from people
I mean these are the things that I feel
are far more important than trying to
get access to the industry in their
press machine which is important don't
get me wrong but relying solely on that
to make your message of your movie and
your work get out there so today from
ten years ago to now I'm not saying you
know this system's wrong but I'm saying
there are other opportunities out there
that can fulfill what you want to do
that don't have to mean going through
the Hollywood media and the Hollywood
studio system in order to achieve what
you really want to do so for me the
evolution was one of feeling I had to be
a part of that and included in it to be
important or successful and instead
realizing that my work and my commitment
to it and the people that it's affecting
was the best that's like the best
compliment you could ever get you know
when you read stories about people who
have gone through some of these
hardships not from a news report but
they're personally telling you that I'm
so glad that you are doing this I am
glad that Hollywood is finally
addressing this or someone out there
heard us when you meet the victims and
the people that have been affected by a
message that you're trying to show of
what's going on out there that is the
most personally at this stage in my
career that is the most rewarding thing
that I have and obviously I would love
to be able to reach a larger group of
people I would love to
be able to work with people in Hollywood
do you see what we're doing is important
I've been told by producers who have
done big time series big-time television
shows movies they're like this is
exactly the kind of stuff that we need
to be promoting these are the kinds of
stories we need to be telling we need to
educate people on the realities of the
world that's going on around us so that
has become now my mission I guess it's
not a political agenda it's one of the
search of your journey through yourself
and and what you believe about the world
around you so it's become something
bigger it's become something I guess you
could say I don't want to like freak
people out but it's spiritual in the
sense of the human self in your heart
and your mind trying to find your deeper
purpose on this planet while you're
still alive and you have this human
family of 7.2 billion people in the
world that need help they need help they
need to they need honesty they need art
they need we need all the things we
talked about when we need art we need we
don't need to destroy art we need to
promote art and art comes from a
truthful place within you and more we do
that I think the better the world can
get at least I'm trying to do my
one-part you know in this little tiny
space in the world that I occupy online
and in reality so I guess you could say
that's been my evolution in the last ten
years of where I saw myself ten years
ago and where I saw myself today and
quite honestly if you had told that guy
in 2008 that this is where I'd be today
I'd go nope I don't want that but the
guy that I am today looking back at my
you know my younger self I would say
dude go for it you have everything to
gain from this experience and wherever
the cards fall or the chips may fall you
can walk through it all learning about
yourself learning about the world around
you and affecting people in real and
meaningful ways and that's just me
that's that may not be everybody but
I I would say as a filmmaker if we pride
ourselves on telling stories that matter
and mean something to people then maybe
we look at how we how we tell stories
who we tell stories to and for who who
do we serve who do we go out there to
embrace and partner with to help get
this message out like organizations or
communities online that exists social
workers I mean it doesn't have to all be
social issues stuff but it that it but
it's a human thing to reach out and
connect with others rather than standing
back here and sort of being in the
industry and loved by the industry and
everything else but really that's fine
you know having friends and you know
connecting with others in the industry
and having your peers and your allies
that's great
but really we're looking at how do we
nourish people's minds and hearts how do
we bring out you know when you show
something that's honest and truthful how
you perceive it how he perceives it how
the next person does it's it's a call to
action inside of you it's up to you what
you want to do or what you want to take
from it or don't but the purpose should
be to try to impact someone show
somebody something that they haven't
seen before something that you learned
in the journey of making this movie
about yourself and the world around you
maybe maybe we could do that a little
bit more and focus on that and if you
really do want to change the world for
the better we could start there possibly
you